the raiders are slowly grinding their
way into a postseason bid
sports director chris matthews telling
us tonight las vegas might not be the
most trendy looking team in the league
but they're winning and getting it done
the old-fashioned way
well the las vegas raiders are coming
off a very impressive win over denver
now it may not have been the most
exciting game
as josh jacobs rushed the ball for 112
yards
he scored two touchdowns it was old
school football but when you've got a
running back like josh jacobs
it's the coach's responsibility to
utilize him you know we have a running
back like josh jacobs you have a
responsibility to
i think surround him with the proper
equipment
to utilize him properly and he needs a
block and tight end he needs a block and
full
to a degree we we kind of take pride in
being able to to run the ball from a two
back set
which is a little bit old school and we
also if you watch us carefully are able
to spread it out
and do some of these modern really cool
rpos
type runs which you know is a thing of
the world now i guess
well the raiders are now 3-0 in the afc
west
6-3 overall but they've got the biggest
test of the season
coming up this sunday night right here
to legion stadium when they welcome the
defending super bowl champions to town
with the las vegas raiders i'm chris
matthews eight sports now
chris thank you still